have to bring up the vietnam draftees
and just how you know some people when
people tell me about whatever group
they're working with
it's the millennials it's the union it's
the
the craft people it's the it's the
nurses it's the doc
they take all these groups of people
whoever they are whatever business we're
working with yeah and they're like well
the thing is with the nurses the thing
is with the millennials they faculty
these groups that no this is the worst
group of people ever
right
because they don't want to listen or
they think they deserve this they think
they deserve that
and i was just my go-to is like
i think the hardest group of human
beings
in the his in history
to deal with was the vietnam draftees
because the vietnam draftees
didn't want to be there they didn't
believe in the war and they could die
doing their job
yeah i'm running through my head right
now
guys were drafted in world war ii and
other wars they were drafted but none of
them were as
unpopular as the vietnam and it was you
know it's debatable whether the vietnam
war was an existential threat so that
that like is
and top it off with
that the massive drug problem and all
the other issues that were coming to a
head inside the ranks and then you've
got to deal with that
yeah
and that trumps anybody else's issues
with
unions or nurses or anything else
yeah
it's any group
i i you know nurses teachers uh
you name the group and there's some
leader
not all leaders but there's a bad leader
out there that says well you know the
thing is with our software engineers is
they think they deserve this they say it
about every single group
you know the thing with millennials they
they think oh oh you know the
this this uh gen x folks they think they
built all this so they think
everybody says that's about everyone so
here's the deal
if you were a good leader in vietnam and
you had draftees which you did
you the good leaders loved the draftees
and they had no issue hackworth's one of
them
because i love what he says he's like
they would actually tell me when i was
screwed up yeah
and he's comfortable enough in his own
skin
to be able to have someone telling me
screwed up and go oh okay well let me
see if i am screwed up or instead of
just going oh
you know shut up or fire and and and
general mukayamoni who was working for
hack said
he i said well what did you think your
draft he said i couldn't tell who was
draftees and who wasn't
i mean come on
treat people with respect
listen to what they have to say
take their input have their back and you
can take guys that are prisoners and
turn them into soldiers that are about
to fight and sacrifice
in the matter of
a dozen hours because he got these guys
like 12 hours before getting to
gettysburg or maybe a little bit longer
but it's it's a quick turnaround time
we're not talking about months where
he's serenading these prisoners
trying to get him to change their minds
you know what else is amazing is imagine
this you're about to go into combat
and up comes the 118th pennsylvania and
goes hey bro not my problem anymore this
is your problem now
there's a lot of people that say yeah
what are you kidding me i'm not taking
these guys or yeah put them over there
lock them to a tree right what i'm not
dealing with this right now and said he
goes okay this is what i got cool i'm
gonna work with it what a what an
awesome attitude
i know i was i was
i would we i definitely took
people in platoons or in the train trade
at where's like hey we got this issue
cool sunroom
let me let me let me work with this dude
let me let me figure out what's going on
instead of being like i don't want him
hey man let's figure out what's going on
with this guy chances are he's probably
a halfway decent dude that just has some
issues going on he's probably going
through a divorce maybe done six
back-to-back deployments i don't know
what's going on but you don't either
when i ask you these questions you don't
even know what's happening with him
you're just telling me he's got a bad
attitude why does they have a bad
attitude
like let give them to me give them to me
i put him in charge of cleaning the head
right another example from
strategy and tactics yeah we'll put him
in charge of something yeah well we did
he still has a bad attitude what was it
or cleaning the head cleaning the
bathrooms on the second deck
[Laughter]
let him run a dive yeah